seit august hat die internationale
raumstation iss ein leck am russischen
teil sie verliert sauerstoff die
kosmonauten suchen krampfhaft nach der
undichten stelle immer noch und die
sauerstoffreserven werden immer kleiner
läuft jetzt die zeit ab muss es früher
verlassen werden als geplant klicks
umsatz im future geht es dreimal pro
woche spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur
so verpasst ihr nichts los herzlich
willkommen und vielen dank für diesen
coolen themenvorschlag denen uns petra
über unsere telegate gruppe geschickt
hat der link zur tätergruppe den jetzt
hier und dort bekommt in die videos
früher und ihr könnt dem vorschlagen und
diskutieren wir kennen es von unseren
autos die älter sie werden desto mehr
geht kaputt und irgendwann lohnt es sich
einfach nicht mehr sie zu reparieren und
genau dieser fall könnte jetzt wird die
international space station iss
eingetreten sein eigentlich hatten die
kosmonauten im russischen teil der
internationalen raumstation iss schon im
oktober gedacht dass das problem behoben
seit damals hatte das team nicht gerade
hightech eingesetzt um die undichte
stelle ausfindig zu machen
man nahm einfach einen teebeutel denn
der teebeutel bewegt sich in der
schwerelosigkeit auf die undichte stelle
zu und tatsächlich in einem übergangs
teil des schwestermodells konnten die
kosmonauten mit diesem teebeutel trick
einen viereinhalb zentimeter langen riss
identifizieren der dann gestoppt wurde
doch das problem war damit nicht behoben
und es trat weiter luft aus im november
dann folgte ein außeneinsatz im weltall
doch trotz intensiver suche wurde man
auch hier nicht ständig mittlerweile
besteht das problem mit dem luft-
austritt und dem druckabfall auf der iss
also schon seit august und so richtig
scheint niemand eine lösung für dieses
problem zu haben
russlands raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos
hält sich eher bedeckt und beschwichtigt
immer wieder wird betont dass es keine
unmittelbare gefahr für die besatzung
auf der ice es gebe demnach stehe man in
ständigem kontakt und austausch mit der
crew mit dem dezember 2020 hatte die
russische staatsagentur tap über eine
schalte berichtet die zwischen der ss
und der leitzentrale in moskau
stattgefunden hatte
demnach sei immer noch nicht klar wo
sich die undicht
stelle befindet nun sei es allerdings
höchste zeit diese zu lokalisieren da
die sauerstoffreserven immer kleiner
würden so die meldung der staatsagentur
tags fachleute vermuten dass sich das
leck an einem übergang zum modul swesda
zu deutsch stern befindet nun werde
diskutiert dass teil hermetisch
abzuriegeln um die luftversorgung weiter
zu gewährleisten also das modul quasi
abzuschotten die arbeiten auf da es
könnten dadurch möglicherweise aber
eingeschränkt werden dazu dimitri
rogosin der chef der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos
es ist alles unter kontrolle es gibt
noch reserven
ein neuer progress raumfrachter mit
neuen sauerstoff vorräten mache sich
bereits im februar auf den weg 2 ss
falls noch mehr sauerstoff notwendig
sein würde man wohl die amerikanischen
partner darum bitten sauerstoff mit
einem eigenen unbemannten transportation
liefert jetzt sind es sieben leute die
zur iss besatzung gehören drei
us-amerikaner ein us amerikanerin ein
japaner und zwei russen es mitte oktober
waren ein us amerikanerin und zwei
russen in rekordzeit zu eis es gelangt
die sojus-rakete erreichte bereits drei
stunden nach ihrem start die kapsel der
ss die rund 400 kilometer über der erde
im weltraum unterwegs ist bis dahin
hatte ein flug doppelt so lange
gebraucht die russen haben das
anflugverfahren immer weiter optimiert
denn ursprünglich dauerte es sogar zwei
tage um die iss zu erreicht wenn jetzt
allerdings die starts den kunden genau
stattfinden können kann die route so
perfekt gewählt werden das flughöhe und
geschwindigkeit der ss in rund drei
stunden erreicht werden
die drei hatten wegen der korona
pandemie übrigens mehr als einen monat
in quarantäne verbracht und waren
mehrmals auf das corona virus getestet
worden
dazu sagten sie wahrscheinlich ist die
internationale raumstation jetzt der
sicherste ort
doch wie lässt sich das leck in der ss
erklären und wie geht es weiter mit
diesem außenposten der menschheit dem
russischen raumfahrt chef dimitri
rogosin zufolge konnten es kleine
meteoriten seien die zitat ermüdung
prozesse des metalls beschleunigen und
klar ist einige der module wurden
bereits vor rund 30 jahren produziert
noch zu sowjetzeiten damals war man
davon ausgegangen dass diese module
maximal 15 jahre im einsatz sein bilden
im herbst hatte sich dazu auch gennadi
padalka geäußert der den rekord für die
längste flugdauer im all
in einem interview sagt er ganz offen
alle module des russischen teils sind
abgenutzt
die iss war zur zeit ihrer entstehung
übrigens gar nicht wirklich als eine
wissenschaft station gedacht sondern
tatsächlich eher als eine reine
machtdemonstration von seiten des
westens sie hatte damit also sogar eine
politische wirkung denn geplant wurde
sie dann doch in den 80er jahren als
gemeinsames projekt von ost und west ein
politisches signal zu zeiten des kalten
krieges dementsprechend auch ihr
steckbrief der innenraum so groß wie ein
jumbo jet ihre fläche vergleichbar mit
einem fußballfeld und gigantische 420
tonnen schwer
das erste mal beeindruckend klingt ist
für ihren eigentlichen zweck eher von
nachteil wenn das alles macht sie
unflexibel groß und unfassbar teuer ihre
ganze organisation nahm ordentlich zeit
in anspruch viele dinge wurden zu
bürokratisch angegangen viel zu langsam
und schwerfällig wurden aufgrund der
konflikte zwischen den beteiligten
partnern auf der erde wichtige
entscheidung getroffen bis experimente
tatsächlich durchgeführt werden konnten
vergingen zum teil sieben und mehr jahre
auch wenn man sagen muss dass sich diese
starren vorgaben im laufe der zeit etwas
gelockert haben mittlerweile ist es
schon 20 jahre her dass eine russische
rakete
das erste modul der internationalen
raumstation iss ins all brachte
seit 20 jahren seit dem jahr 2000 leben
und arbeiten raumfahrer und raumfahrern
an bord der raumstation hat schon viele
begeistert wird zum beispiel auch den
deutschen raumfahrer alexander gerst er
hat im november 2010 von der ss
getwittert die komplexeste wertvollste
und unwahrscheinlichste maschine die die
menschheit jemals gebaut hat zum wohle
aller
wenn wir über kontinente hinweg so
zusammenarbeiten können dann können wir
noch viel mehr zusammen erreichen wir
müssen es nur versuchen doch
mittlerweile ist die iss in die jahre
gekommen noch mindestens vier jahre bis
2024 wollen die nationen die an der
raumstation beteiligt sind diese noch
weiter betreiben doch wird das mit einem
leck funktionieren und wie geht es dann
mit ihr weiter das steht noch in den
sternen immer wieder wird auch darüber
gesprochen dass es möglicherweise doch
auch noch bis zum jahr 2030 weiter zu
betreiben allerdings ermüdet die
stationen immer mehr und das leck ist
nur eines von vielen problemen roskosmos
die russische weltraumagentur überlegt
module abzubauen und für an
die stationen zu verwenden die usa
dagegen überlegen ob sich der betrieb
ihres nasa zu privatisieren lassen
könnte private unternehmen wie spacex
beispielsweise könnten dann
weltraumtouristen 2 ss fliegen
betrachtet man die ice es rein technisch
könnte sie zumindest in der theorie
bis zum jahr 2028 im einsatz sein
danach folgt dann möglicherweise auch
ein absturz ins meer kontrolliert
natürlich denn ihre länge von mehr als
100 metern erlaubt es auf gar keinen
fall dass die ss als weltraumschrott
durch das all fliegt in der
vergangenheit gab es so einige pannen
auf der iss da ist das lag nur die
spitze des eisbergs so gingen zum
beispiel die toilette und die
sauerstoffversorgung kaputt und in die
werkstatt kann man die ice es nicht
bringen die besatzung selbst muss wie
auch jetzt beim lag die station selbst
ständig repariert das sauerstoff problem
sei ein zeichen der station wird dmitri
rogozin der chef der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde roskosmos demnach gehe
es mit der ss ihrem ende entgegen zitat
es ist zeit für mich in rente zu gehen
und damit meint er nicht sich selbst
sondern die raumstation bis 2024 oder
eben möglicherweise sogar bis 2028 aber
werde die ice es wohl noch durchhalten
so rogosin
wir drücken die daumen und erinnern noch
an einen anderen ice es notfalls
sabotage auf der internationalen
raumstation iss da geht es um ein
achtung loch auf da ist es von dem wir
bis heute noch nicht erfahren haben wer
ist eigentlich kam sicher ist es wurde
von menschenhand gebohrt welche
verdachtsmomente es gab erfahrt ihr in
diesem video also anklicken anschauen
und abonnieren
ich würde mich wirklich freuen wenn ihr
gig zum regelmäßig schauen würde denn
ich versuche hier wirklich grundlegende
themen gründlich aber auch verständlich
zu erklären also wenn er das mit
clustern aber da bis dann bleibt